joining us now author of the upcoming
book silent no more how I became a
political prisoner of Muller's which on
jerome corsi is with us you said I'm not
taking the plea deal I know I could go
to jail for the rest of my life a lot of
this revolves around the text message
that was sent to you by Roger who you
just heard that you didn't remember you
amending your testimony numerous times
because you didn't remember what you
wrote or said two years ago
that's correct and what the special
prosecutor is asking me to do is accept
a fraudulent plea which I am gonna have
my attorneys file criminal charges on
with the Department of Justice my
experience made it clear to me that the
political criminals are running the
Department of Justice and Mueller's
prosecution I was ridiculed my testimony
was laughed at they yawned on it they
misbehaved and they accused me of being
a liar and a fabricator I think which
was an attack on me for the books I've
written that have been so successful
twenty books since 2000 oh when you
wrote unfit to get let me ask you this
you spent how many hours before Muller
and his team I was there for 40 hours
approximately let me ask you this when
they were offering you this plea deal
which they even said might just result
in probation maybe no jail time at all
when that you were confronted with that
opportunity because you're right you're
72 years old you may be if this could be
a life sentence for you in jail but when
they were talking to you were they
telling you what in your opinion what
they wanted to hear and if you said it
you get off scot-free oh absolutely
in fact my attorney said all they want
you to say is that what were they
telling you they wanted to hear well
they want to hear that I had a source
connected to Assange or I did some way
get a direct contact with us on so they
could do the connection which would go
all Roger stone Jerry Corsi Assange and
then they'd have their basis for
collusion it was complete nonsense but
they would not accept when I told them
that in fact I never menace on
I had no contact with Assange or
intermediary you never you never had any
contact with Julian Assange or WikiLeaks
absolutely none
never never stay right there if you can
stay we're gonna hold you over Jerome
Corsi my interview now with your own
course EU decided to turn down a plea
deal agreement with the special counsels
office he says he's committed no crime
all right you never spoke to Julian
Assange you never met him you never
spoke to anyone at WikiLeaks any
surrogate that's correct I never did
okay let me go back then to August 2nd
2016 and you said and wrote word is a
friend in embassy plans two more dumps
referring to Julian Assange and
WikiLeaks one shortly after own back
second in October impact plan to be very
damaging so if you don't know him how
did you know that well because it was a
manner deduction I had expert and
analysis and information how the
Democrats put their computer system
together the release of information in
July 22nd 2016 that got Debbie
wasserman-schultz was taken from the DNC
email server but it only included
officials who were not John Podesta I
said John Podesta is missing here and I
knew whoever stole emails from that
server had John Podesta
and I said if I had John Podesta Z mails
I'd keep them until the end I make him
as making him October Surprise you
deduce that they had to him because of
the same server same server had to go to
The Wall Street Journal then he said
what I construct and what I testified to
the grand jury was I believed I was
creating a cover story for Roger meaning
Roger stone because Roger wanted to
explain the tweet that I had earlier
asked him about and by the way the
special counsel knew this they can tell
virtually my keystrokes on that computer
Roger said that's not logical and said
that that you were being squeezed by
Muller's prosecutors when you said that
can you can you shed some light on that
yeah two points very quickly first of
all they constantly pressed me about
what Roger thought and I told him it was
a shame I didn't take the mind-reading
course at Harvard
I can't tell you what somebody else is
thinking and listening to Roger tonight
sounds like that's Rogers explanation
I'll accept that that's what Roger was
thinking in terms of what I'm trying to
you trying to say as you said we used
trying to create a cover story for Roger
we answered that in politics is in
public relations I was trained in public
relations by Edward Bernays the founder
of it you know you create narratives to
benefit your client you know British
Petroleum's going after oil reserves all
over the world becomes BP and suddenly
it's beyond petroleum well BP is no more
beyond oil than Long John Silver was
beyond Ludi is that a lie mm-hmm okay
let me ask you this you you actually
said the following you said I in my
heart I went in to tell the truth did my
best to tell the truth and I won't swear
before God and a judge something I I
consider to be a lie we're talking about
2-year old emails mr. korsky two years
old and then you acknowledge the times
that you had forgotten some of the
emails you could have possibly gotten no
jail time none at all and now you might
as you even said risk dying in jail
you're you're older you're 72 years old
look I'm we all worried at this point
our lives right yes why because what and
here's my bigger question what did you
know they were trying to get you to say
they wanted what do they want they
wanted me a name a source with WikiLeaks
that I had that told me Assange had
Podesta's emails and answer your other
question the plea deal they were offered
I had to go before his federal judge and
swear under God with the and to a
federal judge that I knowingly and
willfully submitted false information
that I knew to be false to the federal
authorities in order to mislead them I
didn't do that I'd rather spend States
has come to it I'll spend the rest of my
life in jail but I will not swear under
God to Allah I won't do it
and and but you do admit you listen I
can't tell you who was on my show last
week so you know if I'm in the same
position unless I reviewed all my emails
and went back and looked at it at a time
I wouldn't remember I don't know who was
on the show last week I get
Regan's accomplishments from the 1980s
but i can't tell you who was on let me
let me ask you this because i think this
is very very important and you know if
you didn't have any communications and
you didn't know and your did you ever
because looking for op researchers in a
crime and we'll get to our attorneys
next if you conspired to steal hack into
somebody's personal emails or whatever
had any doings with that that would be a
crime did you do any of those things
absolutely not
i deduced that song had Podesta's emails
i knew what they were gonna be in how
damaging they were gonna be and how they
were used but i'm not a human tape
recorder you can't punch a button and
have me recite word-for-word a
conversation or an email i did two years
ago and that's where the prosecutors
demanded they ridiculed me they yawn
they got up in the room they abused me
all kinds of ways psychologically and
they did that to coerce me to make me
from dale one think that if i didn't
tell them what they wanted to hear i was
gonna go to prison for the rest of my
life and die there and did they say that
to you it made it very clear this was
serious offenses and there could be
multiple charges and let me ask you this
i remember when you wrote the the book
on john kerry and we had you on many
times yes you know i'm reading what the
media writes about you that you didn't
believe the moon landing was real or
that 9/11 just i want to get it accurate
was an inside job i don't know if you
believe those things are not um do you
because I was surprised that's all
fabrication I don't believe do it but
you're getting to a very important point
Aaron szalinski but the part of the
prosecutors said ridiculed me he said
you just take this fact that fact you
make lies well I know he's ridiculing my
work on you know a Barack Obama the
birth certificate in his foot boats I'm
being persecuted and prosecuted because
you're like wants to get rid of me as
controversial opinions and views I would
disagree with you on both of those
things but it's this isn't what's that
issue here was my issue here is were you
offered basically freedom if you told
lies and you're saying they wanted you
to lie
they were pushing you to lie yes if I
had given them what they wanted it would
be all happy happy and then in fact
after the first grand jury testimony
they all shook my hand and congratulated
me and they blew it up in the second
round because I did not have a source
with WikiLeaks they blew it up for that
reason
all right jerome corsi thank you for
being with us we wish you the best of
luck